[Music]
uh hello everyone this is uh Grandmaster
Victor
meski uh today I'm going to show you
some uh brilliant moments from uh my own
games and the first game uh I want to
show you uh the game I played against
the American
Grandmaster Gregory
kaidanov I played this game with the uh
uh black
pieces and uh we reached the position on
the
diagram so um uh black to
move uh you can take your time trying to
uh figure it out and then I'll uh show
the
solution
I don't think I'm ever GNA find these
okay so you want me to show you the
solution then
right okay
so maybe maybe not her
so B basically the trick
is that uh black wants to play Queen
takes A4 check getting the pawn the king
moves away and then the Knight goes to
G4 the Knight sacrifice with the idea of
Queen H2 Checkmate but in this case
white just
takes with the pawn if the queen goes to
H6 white can block with the Rook or with
the bishop right so it's not not going
uh uh direct it's not working directly
but there is a nice way to uh make it
work okay and the move is Rook to
d8 The Rook
sacrifice a very interesting
move so say white takes yeah because the
Rook is under
attack and then black plays
queen queen takes F4 check
King
H1 and Knight to
G4 so as you can see what black has
already sacrificed the rook and he's
ready to sacrifice the bishop on eight
with the check and the knight in order
to uh deliver a
Checkmate so Rook takes E8
check King to
G7 H takes
G4 and queen H6
check so after Bishop H3 Queen takes H3
and white gets checkm
it right so a very nice sequence which
started with the move Rook
d8 uh of course white is not really
forced to take the Rook on D but then uh
he's probably going to lose slowly like
for instance after the move Knight
D1 which is the best
defense uh but uh black will be up a
pawn anyway and
uh probably a winning position after a
few exchanges like
this okay let let's move on to the next
position
uh this this uh position is taken from
uh uh my game against alone Greenfield
from Israel in fact the uh current
position didn't really occur in the game
but it could have
ured uh and uh the idea which I'm going
to show you uh was shown me by my
opponent he calculated this line during
the
game so this is a uh position why to
move I play it with the black
pieces
so any any
ideas not really that would much of
anything okay do you want me to show
you sure so the move Knight
G5 white sacrifices the bishop on
G2 Bishop takes
G2 so what's the
point
so the point is in fact to play Knight
to
E6 the queen on d8 is trapped and so
basically black is forced to capture the
knight in fact if they capture the
Knight immediately they get checkm
Queen takes G6
check king f8 and the bishop comes to
H6 so Bishop G7 takes and check
mate a nice Checkmate here but uh black
can try instead of taking the Knight
right away playing Bishop to
E4 the intermediate move uh
counterattacking White Queen so no time
to take the queen on d8 white is going
to take Queen takes
E4 and then black has another
intermediate move Knight
F6 and this move makes a way to the
queen so the queen is not trapped
anymore so after Knight F6 white has
another nice move Queen to
H1 moving the queen away from the attack
and attacking the bishop on
h8 and after F takes E6 Queen takes h8
check and this position probably is
roughly
equal my opponent saw this idea but
didn't play in the
game and eventually lost the game
because of
that so a really really nice uh idea
sacrificing two pieces and a very
unusual
one okay next uh
position so
uh uh the next uh game uh is my game
against the Israeli gem Yakov
zilberman um I played uh this game with
the uh White
pieces and white has a really uh nice
idea
here at the moment black is up a piece
but his King is in a very dangerous
position on uh
H5 so how do we exploit uh Black's uh
King
position okay if you play G four then
just uh F
takes H takes Bishop
takes Knight takes
F7 okay Knight F7 in fact is
not is not such a bad
idea so uh black is probably going to
take back on F7 yeah Knight F7 queen of
s Rook takes G5 check okay then black
takes
back could you back with the PA right
away G4 M then F
takes then if you take with h pawn
bishop
takes
okay Alex is asking about the first game
against kaidanov how long did it take to
find the move Rook D in fact in the game
I didn't find the
move and uh still once
again H which move F3 F3 F3 with IDE of
G4 yeah
um yeah looks kind of slow and
uh black can maybe even takes the Knight
on
E5 cuz G4 is not yet a Checkmate
right so if F3 Queen takes
E5 we we can see it on the board say if
F3 Queen E5 and then G4 and then G4 uh
okay let's say even King H4 is an
option also taking should be not so
bad okay let's say takes
once which one H or F
Pawn okay say King
H4 then Queen G3
check yeah and black Queens right
yeah okay so it's not going to
work
H4 H4 is a tricky
move
um um no not sure if black needs to take
that
pawn so the dips is suggesting
uh H4 maybe black can even try Bishop to
F4 to keep the H6 Square under
control okay so V Kesh is saying Rook H6
check and what if Bishop takes
H6 would you sacrifice The Rook
on
G5 yeah Rook Rook G5 yeah is one one of
the possible ways to continue so Rook
takes G5 King takes
G5 okay so pan suggested playing after
Rook takes Queen E3
check
um but then let's say uh Black Blocks
with F
Pawn
yeah so so after Rook G5 King G5 Queen
E3 F4 I don't think there is any follow
up there
right so we we can see it on the board
like if takes takes Queen E3 check and
uh black can just play
F4 I don't think there is any
followup if you play
H4 it's black black has a few options I
believe
even just going back to H6 should be
fine so let's go
back Bishop takes and then
what
F takes and H Bishop takes
G4 okay let let me show
you okay it takes some time for you to
find the idea okay there are in fact uh
at least three winning moves Rook takes
G5 by the way is one of them but then
the correct follow up is uh uh Knight
takes F7 Queen takes F7 and now the move
F4 but uh what I wanted to show you is
not this line even though it should
still win for white but the beautiful
move which wins the game is Queen to D6
the idea is to come with the queen to
D1 but what's the point what if black
just takes the queen right
right that should be the main
question what can why do in this
case uh taking the queen with a rook but
then you're down a piece
right Rook takes Bishop that's right
deeps if very nice
move now black is forced to take the
Rook if the King goes to H4 the Knight
F3 is a
Checkmate the king also cannot go to H6
because then Knight takes F7 is a
Checkmate so King takes G5 is the only
move and then Knight takes F7 with a
fork white gets back the queen and now
White is up a
pawn and
uh and has a clear
Advantage so once again in the starting
position it's Queen to
D6 yeah I also think it's a very nice
idea okay let's move
on next position I play it uh
this game with the white pieces against
another Israeli and current American
Grandmaster Serge
arenburg I played with the white pieces
and now it's white to
move I had a beautiful tactical idea in
this position which I missed during the
game
Rook to A1 but in case of Rook to A1 uh
black can just take the bishop on
e4 and stop the Checkmate on
eight
beight
D6 Knight to
D6
um Knight to D6 so
probably black can uh move the Bish The
Rook away like say after Knight D6 Rook
E6 and the bishop on e4 is still pinned
right so I don't know if Knight D6
really does that
much okay if Bishop takes Rook then Rook
takes
E1 B7 B7 doesn't really create threats
and so black can just take the bishop on
e4 okay it I se bone says Knight to E5
and this is the correct
answer a very nice move which blocks the
E file the point is that if black takes
with the
Rook then uh White has Bishop D6 check
followed by B7 check and white promotes
the B
Pawn so taking with the Rook is
impossible uh if black takes with the
bishop then white can get take the Rook
on
F3 so the bishop on e4 is not pinned
anymore so black cannot take the Rook on
E1 and even though black still has a
trick here black can play Bishop D4
check a discovered attack on E1 then
white simply takes Rook takes E1 check
and King to F2 and white has bishop and
two pawns for the rook and a slightly
better position
white so another try for black is Rook
G3
check moving The Rook away from the
attack and uh hoping to take the Knight
on
E5 then white plays Bishop to
G2
and it turns out that once again Black
is Black cannot take the Knight on E5
with the rook in view of Bishop D6
check if he takes with a
bishop then Rook takes E5 is
possible and after Rook takes Bishop D6
check so the best try is taking on G2
first first eliminating the bishop and
only Z taking on E5 but in this case
black white plays Bishop D6 check King
B7 Bishop takes E5 and uh black uh needs
to escape with the draw which he can do
it in fact by playing Bishop E4
check and next move G6 and black should
be
safe so after Bishop
G2 okay same uh if uh black starts with
Rook takes G2 King takes G2 and then
plays Bishop takes
E5 White Steel sacrifices The Rook on
E5 gives a check and once again we reach
the same position which is uh a
draw so in fact in the start in the
starting position uh White escapes uh uh
with a draw by playing Knight
E5
okay let's move
on uh this uh in this game I played with
the uh black
pieces against
uh fed master from uh Canada iron
Finley so it's black to move uh in the
diagram
position okay good job
it who already found the move uh Bishop
to
B1 a very nice move which has the point
of playing F7 next uh sorry C2
next to protect the bishop and then
black can play Bishop to
B2 in case of Rook to takes B1 black
plays C2 with a double attack on two
Rooks yeah indeed Bishop B1 is a very
difficult move uh to
find okay
next next uh uh
game uh I played this one again with the
black pieces against uh Finster waler
Sebastian and here uh I missed a very uh
nice uh tactical
idea
so black to
move so why why is straightening to play
G3
G4
spe
so in the game I played the move Bishop
E6 trying to avoid the fork with
G4 but in fact the move G4 can be
allowed indeed it's not uh it's not easy
to
find Alex so yeah I I also didn't find
it during the
game so let me show you the first move
try to find the followup
so the first move is Rook a to
E8 which allows the move
G4 yes it it's indeed r a to
E8 but what's the
followup
if Knight F4 just Bishop
F4
uh Bishop takes G4 and then F5
takes uh check with a knight no it's not
going to
work so G4 Bishop
G4 F takes G4 Knight F4 check just
Bishop takes F4
okay let let me show you it's not uh
it's not easy at all in fact I saw the
idea but just miscalculated
it so the idea is indeed Bishop takes
G4 and F takes
G4 I am homeless on WiFi is correct
Bishop G4 F takes G4 and Bishop D4
indeed the idea is to deflect the Bishop
from the F4
Square so after Bishop takes D4 we don't
even play Knight F4 right away we play
first Rook takes E2
check a very nice move the point is that
we remove the bishop in order to take
the G4 pawn and white is unable to take
back with the queen in view of Knight F4
check a nice
Fork so uh during the game I calculated
the line with Knight G2
E2 Queen takes G4 check Knight to
G3 Knight F4 check and King G1 and
stopped my calcul a here because I
didn't see her to win in this
position but it turns out that black has
a quiet move Queen
F3 straightening Knight H3
Checkmate and uh black doesn't and white
doesn't have a good
defense the best white can do is Queen
takes F4 black just
takes Knight C2 E2
Queen D2 and uh black gets a winning
position black gets queen and a lot of
pawns for rook and two minor pieces so
this should be winning and another
possible uh uh capture is Knight C takes
E2 in this case still Queen takes G4
check Knight G3 Knight F4
check now the king can not even go to G1
because the Knight is
there so once again white has to give up
the queen queen takes
A4 Queen takes F4 Bishop C3 and queen
takes C4 and once again black achieves a
winning
position so let's see it from the very
beginning Rook a to8 a quiet
move and after G4 Bishop takes F takes
so sacrif iing one Bishop then
sacrificing the second bishop and then
sacrificing in exchange on
E2 and
uh and black queens yeah of course uh of
course G4 is not forced but then black
is just better if U if white doesn't
play G4 G4 is a critical move but uh it
just doesn't
work
okay let's move on next
game uh I played this game with the
black pieces against the Dutch gem
Ernest
sip uh so this position accurate in the
analysis of the game not in the real
game so it's uh way to
move
no it's white to move not black to
move sorry I'll uh flip the board for
you so Knight F6 check Bishop takes
F6
for
so Knight takes F6 Knight F6 Bishop
takes F6 Pawn takes F6 Rook takes E2 and
in case of Rook D check black can block
with the Rook so it's not a
Checkmate okay the here is a suggestion
Knight F6 Bishop F6 Rook d8
check but then uh but then King G7 and
white doesn't see her to
win okay Alex is saying after Rook D
check Rook
E8 and then taking on F6 but black can
just take the Rook on
D
well uh it I suggesting Queen D2 but
that's a little
slow yeah it's not easy but
beautiful
no deeps it's not Queen to
G4
okay it seems that time homeless on
Wi-Fi found the
idea so let let's see it Knight F6 check
Bishop takes
F6 Rook D check so now black has two
options uh first king G7 and then e
takes
F6 let's see first king
G7 that's uh that's probably the best uh
option for black then e takes F6 check
King takes
F6 Queen B2
check King to
G5 H4 check the King goes to
H6 and now Rook to
G8 creating a threat of Queen uh D2
check so black can give a check from
here King H2 and play F5 covering the G7
Square
and now after the move Queen B4 with a
double attack on E7 and queen F4 check
black can sacrifice The Rook with Queen
F3 Queen takes E7 and queen takes F2
check forcing a
draw so that's a nice escape from black
but if black plays Rook e instead which
looks like a natural
move white has a really beautiful win
which is Queen to
E4 white sacrifices the
queen so uh the point is if uh if black
takes Queen takes
E4 white takes with a check on
E8 the King goes to G7 and then e takes
F6 a Discover It attack and white gets
the queen on
E4 so uh if if black plays Queen B5
trying to keep the Rook protected then
A4
wins so uh Rook takes d8 is probably the
best defense Queen takes A4 Bishop takes
E5 Queen takes a seven and
uh this position is better for white but
uh black still retains chances for a
draw okay so let's move on the next
uh next position is from my game against
valo pawns the Spanish uh
Grandmaster I played this game with the
black pieces and it's black to move in
the current
position
Bishop to A6 check is a suggestion but
then King goes to
E1 okay it TI It bone uh is showing the
correct move Bishop to
C3 so uh so what's the trick here the
point is that black is threatening to
play Rook takes
C5 and the B Pawn is pinned black can
take the bishop on
A5 and what's also important is that if
white takes on C black has a very strong
intermediate move Bishop to A6
check and it turns out the King on E2
doesn't have any
moves and so black gets two
Rooks white would have to block with the
uh Rook on D3 and black can just take on
C8 and next The Rook on D3 is going to
fall so that's why in the game uh uh my
opponent found a nice tactical uh uh
defense he played Rook to
D4 so he's giving up an exchange but uh
uh wants to keep uh practical chances
so if say I take Bishop takes D4 then he
takes with the E Pawn and gets strong
pass
pawns especially after the exchange on
C5 he he has good chances here so after
Rook D4 I first took Rook takes
C5 B takes C5 then I took the Rook on
D4 e takes
D4 and Bishop takes D5
now black is up in exchange and
eventually I managed to uh convert my
material
advantage it still wasn't easy because
uh White uh White has some chances
thanks to the Past Pawn on the
C5 okay so next
position I played with the black pieces
with the black pieces against the
Israeli International Master Mel
nidora uh so it's black to
move
Rook takes F3 okay let's
see uh after Rook takes
F3 uh probably white is forced to take
with the G
Pawn cuz if Rook takes and queen E1
check followed by Bishop D4
check so Rook takes F3 G takes
F3 so after G takes Bishop D4 check King
H1 and queen E2 but then white plays
Queen to D1
so Bishop D4 check right away and King
H1
e
the position is indeed very good but
still black has to find
something
decisive okay it is winning but black
needs to find
it
deep says Bishop to
H3 and after G
takes okay okay in fact it's a
combination of two ideas First bishop D4
check the King has to go to
H1 and now Bishop to
H3 that's a really beautiful move
because the idea behind is behind it is
to take Rook takes
F3 when the G Pawn is spinned and The
Rook can cannot take because of Queen
E1 surprisingly why doesn't have any
defense in this
position for instance uh if uh White
plays Queen C2 bringing the queen back
simply Rook takes F3 The Rook cannot
take because of the checkmate on the
back Rank and after G takes Bishop takes
F1
winning if black plays Bishop to D1
moving the bishop away from the attack
then Queen E4 is coming attacking the G2
pawn and if say white protects with the
queen something like Queen
C2 black can still play Rook takes
D1
deflecting the queen from uh
G2 and if white plays Bishop to F3 and
once again Rook takes
F3 and after G takes Queen E2 and black
wins
and finally if white takes G takes H3
after Bishop
H3 then black plays Rook takes F3
sacrificing The
Rook Rook takes Queen E1 check and queen
G1
Checkmate okay let's move
on
next position which ured in the analysis
of uh my game against Dimitri Tomkin
Grandmaster Mitri tkin from
Israel and uh if I played
inaccurately uh I could have lost
because of this
idea fortunately I I saw it in
advance
this one though is rather
standard okay and the ties correct Rook
takes
F6 is the
move the Rook sacrifice
uh and
black black has to accept because uh
after Queen takes
D2 white can just play Rook F7 check and
when the King goes to the uh D file Rook
D1 and The Queen Is
Lost so uh black has to accept the
sacrifice Rook F1
check King to
E7 Queen F7
check the King has to go to
D6 Knight C4
check forcing King C5 now the queen goes
to F2
check sacrificing also the
Knight if black takes the
Knight then white plays B3
check and now black has uh two moves
even three
moves if the King goes back to B5 then
A4 check is
coming King to
A6 Queen E2 check and queen B5
Checkmate if the king takes this S three
Pawn then Rook C1
check King D3 Queen F3
check the king can go to D4 in view of
Rook C4
Checkmate and if the King goes to D2
then Queen C3 check King D2 and Rook E1
checkm so after Queen F2 check uh black
should try Knight
D4 but then after the simple Knight
takes E5 uh White achieves a winning
position next move is C takes D4 and
black will be unable to take back in
view of Rook C1 check and black loses
the
queen so white will have the decisive
attack
here
okay
MH so next game I played with the
uh uh White pieces against the Israeli
uh International Master uh
canari and in fact it's black to move in
this
position I believe it didn't Ur in the
real
game but uh the idea is very nice and
uh and rather useful for this type of
positions so black to
move
so the idea the idea itself is
positional but you need to calculate
precisely to make this
move
in fact the move is A5 to
A4 if you play Knight C5 white can play
uh
B4 yes you're right then then it's A4
indeed so what's the point now if white
takes the pawn on
A4 black sacrifices the Knight on A4
Knight takes E4 Rook takes E4 then
sacrifices an exchange on
A4 Queen takes then f4 on
C5 Queen to
C2 Knight takes
E4 and if white takes the Knight then
Bishop F5 at the end if the Rook wasn't
on B one the entire combination wouldn't
work so it turns it turns out that uh
black white shouldn't take the A4 Pawn
but then uh black black achieved a very
a nice position but by playing next
Knight C5
and and so A5 A4 is a very good
move
okay uh thank you very much everyone for
uh watching and
uh uh I see you all
[Music]
[Applause]
soon